KEEP TELLING YOURSELF THOSE
LIES.
AND THAT'S "THE ANGLE."
JOINING ME NOW, STEPHEN MILLER,
FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
OF "THE FEDERALIST."
IF THEY THOUGHT THEIR POLICIES
WERE SO POPULAR, WOULD THEY BE
RUNNING TO THE ABORTION ISSUE SO
ENTHUSIASTICALLY?
>> FIRST OFF, I DON'T THINK
ABORTION AS GOOD OF AN ISSUE FOR
THEM AS THEY THINK.
THEIR VIEW IS INCREDIBLY
EXTREME.
EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRAT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY BELIEVES THAT ABORTION
SHOULD BE ALLOWED THROUGH ALL
NINE MONTHS OF PREGNANCY FOR ANY
REASON.
IF YOU WANT TO KILL AN UNBORN
CHILD BECAUSE SHE'S A GIRL, THEY
THINK IT SHOULD BE FINE.
REPUBLICAN POSITION IS SIMPLY
THAT STATES SHOULD BE ABLE TO
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS THEMSELVES.
I'M NOT SURE IF PEOPLE THINK
ABOUT THE ISSUES WHETHER THE
ARGUMENT WILL WORK, BUT
OBVIOUSLY THE REAL ISSUES ARE
THE ONES THAT PEOPLE REALLY CARE
ABOUT IN THEIR DAY-TO-DAY THAT
SAYS THE ECONOMY, INFLATION, THE
BORDER, WHICH IS COMPLETELY OPEN
IN THE SOUTH.
A CRIME WHICH IS RAMPANT IN SO
MANY CITIES AND WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN OUR SCHOOLS.
DEMOCRATS DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
SAY ABOUT IT.
B1 CAN YOU BELIEVE THE D.C.
STORY?
THE KIDS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO GO
VIRTUAL.
THESE PEOPLES ARE FRAUDS, THESE
PEOPLE ARE FRAUDS.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT YOUR
CHILDREN OR YOU WILL, IT'S ABOUT
THE REAL DICTATORSHIP OF IDEAS.
I'M SORRY, I'M SO UPSET ABOUT
THE SCHOOL ISSUE.
HERE'S WHAT BIDEN SAID IN A
FUND-RAISER THAT OCCURRED BEFORE
HIS 30 MINUTE RANT TONIGHT AND
SCREWED UP TRAFFIC OVER D.C.
WE ARE SEEING NOW THE BEGINNING
OR THE DEATH KNELL OF AN EXTREME
MAGA AGENDA.
NOT JUST TRUMP, IT'S ALMOST
SEMIFASCISM.
IN STEPHEN.
>> FOR THAT I WOULD CALL THAT
PROJECTION.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WITH A
FASCIST PARTY IS, IT'S
JOE BIDEN'S DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHAT IS FASCISM?
RATING THE HOME OF THE POLITICAL
OPPONENT?
PURELY POLITICAL REASONS?
SHUTTING DOWN PEOPLE'S LIVES AND
BUSINESSES, KICKING PEOPLE OUT
OF THE SCHOOLS BECAUSE THEY WILL
NOT GET YOUR VACCINE?
LEAVING PEOPLE AT THE MERCY OF
CRIMINALS WHILE WEAPONIZING
JUSTICE AGAINST YOUR POLITICAL
OPPOSITION?
THOSE ARE FASCIST ACTIONS.
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE IS FASCIST?
FOR GIVING STUDENT LOAN DEBT
GOING AROUND CONGRESS WITH NO
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY INSTEAD
OF ASKING FOR A LAW.
ALL ACTIVITIES ARE FASCIST AND
REPUBLICAN SHOULD POINT OUT THAT
WE ARE NOW THE FREEDOM PARTY AND
THEY ARE NOW THE PARTY OF
TYRANNY AND OPPRESSION.
>> Laura: AND CONTROL, FROM
AIR-CONDITIONING TO GAS POWERED
VEHICLES.
HERE'S ANOTHER STELLAR MOMENT
FROM BIDEN'S RENT FEST THIS
EVENING.
>> IT'S NOT HYPERBOLE, THE VERY
SURVIVAL OF OUR PLANET.
IT'S NOT HYPERBOLE, NOW YOU NEED
TO VOTE TO LITERALLY SAVE
DEMOCRACY AGAIN.
>> Laura: KIDS, GET OFF MY
LAWN.
>> THAT'S THE DEFINITION OF
HYPERBOLE, BUT THIS TYPE OF
RHETORIC REALLY IS FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE OF ANYTHING ABOUT THE
DEFINITION OF FASHION AND SOME
THE JOINING OF CORPORATIONS WITH
THE PARTY.
JUST TONIGHT, WE SAW
MARK ZUCKERBERG SAYS THE FBI HAD
FACEBOOK CENSOR THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP INFORMATION.
THAT'S WHAT SO MANY TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES ARE DOING IN CONGRESS
WITH THE PARTY.
IT THAT'S FASCISM AND SOMETHING
EVERYONE SHOULD HATE WHETHER
THEY'RE REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT
AND IT'S HAPPENING AND AFFECTING
OUR FREEDOM.
>> Laura: SPEAKING OF MOLLY'S
POINT, GOOGLE ANNOUNCED IT WAS
GOING TO UNDERTAKE A
DISINFORMATION SCRUB IN EUROPE.
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENING IN
EUROPE, THEY WANT TO BRING HERE.
IT'S ULTIMATELY HAPPENING.
A DISINFORMATION SCRUB.
>> THE CHINESE SYSTEM HERE IN
AMERICA AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
ADMIRE ESPECIALLY --
>> Laura: WHAT'S YOUR SOCIAL
CREDIT SCORE TONIGHT?
I DON'T EVEN THINK YOU'RE RIGHT
ON THIS ONE.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE GETTING
DEMOCRACY LECTURES FROM THE
LOCKDOWN PARTY?
PEOPLE THAT STOLE THE CHILDHOOD
OF MILLIONS OF STUDENTS AND
WOULDN'T LET THEM GO TO SCHOOL
AND STILL NOT LETTING THEM GO TO
SCHOOL?
DEMOCRACY LECTURES FROM THE
PRESIDENT WHO IS ILLEGALLY
VIOLATING THE LAW EVERY DAY BY
KEEPING THE BORDER OPEN DESPITE
DECADES OF LOSS PASSED BY
CONGRESS AND THE BORDER HAS TO
BE SECURE IN THE LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS DEPORTED?
THIS IS A MAN WHO HAS CONTEMPT
FOR DEMOCRACY AND CONTEMPT FOR
CONGRESS AND CONTEMPT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: 41.5% IS THE
APPROVAL FOR BIDEN.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY BREAKING ABOUT
THAT.
THAT'S A BREAK FOR THEM.
>> I HEARD PEOPLE SAY THAT
THINGS ARE GOING BETTER FOR
BIDEN.
>> Laura: LIKE THE MOMENTUM.
TO SPEAK OF THE NUMBERS ARE
LOWER AND THE POLICIES ARE SO
DEEPLY UNPOPULAR THAT THE
FUNDAMENTALS OF THE ELECTION
WILL REMAIN THE SAME AND THE OUT
PARTY WHICH IS A REBEL GUN PARTY
SHOULD STAND TO GAIN.
THEY
NEED TO ARTICULATE WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO.
>> Laura: I HAVE TO ASK YOU
BECAUSE YOU READ A GREAT COLUMN
ABOUT THIS.
AT THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND GREAT THING
ABOUT THE CANDIDATES.
I'M DONE WITH THAT AND THEY GOT
TO STOP THAT.
AT LEAST PEOPLE ARE COURAGEOUS
TO BE IN THE SPRING RIGHT NOW.
FIRST-TIME CANDIDATES, BLAKE
MASTERS, HERSCHEL WALKER.
>> YOU HAVE A POINT WHERE THEY
DON'T LIKE THE DIRECTION OF THE
A COUNTRY.
IF THE LEADERSHIP CAN'T SUPPORT
THE CANDIDATES.
AND SPEAK OF THEIR LIFE OF THE
REPUBLIC IS AT STAKE
>> Laura: THE LIFE OF THE
PLANET.
IT